most people think of hell is like a
place where bad people go and it just
gets worse for them I'd like to think of
Hell as where bad people go and everyone
that does bad things meets each other
and they can talk about kind of like a
therapy group I think right now I'm at a
stage where I'm kind of confused with
religion religion matters to me because
if people don't believe in God then like
they won't go to heaven and it's better
to be in heaven than help
why does religion matter to you that's a
good question it's just a big part of my
life I don't know if you did bad sins in
your life and never asked for
forgiveness you go to hell where you're
punished for further your when you're
dead most people who do bad things are
also not very mentally stable and that's
not always their fault if people kill
people I think don't go to hell can you
draw us a picture of what you imagine
hell looks like okay I'm gonna kind of
base it off the nether and minecraft
take a portal to go there and there's a
lot of bad creatures I think cats are
evil how might be full of cats and
there's fire everywhere and it's already
an orange in yellow
I think the devil Jesus decides if you
go to hell I don't think of it as like a
devil or with you're on fire it could
just be like you're asleep and you never
come up I mean that could be what death
is like you're never gonna know until
you find out I think how might be
underground I like red and dark
volcanoes I almost don't want to use red
because that's not really how I want to
think them helps oh I found read it I
imagine it's like really hot I think it
would be even hotter than LA devil see
in my religion we call it sheet time I
think the volcanoes are always erupting
in hell I imagine it's something bad
like carrying a whole big wheelbarrow
full of heavy stuff I think people go to
hell forever if you do bad things you go
to hell and there's no way out after you
go to hell you can go to heaven because
it's made you a better person it will
make no sense to let these people burn
or be with the devil I think it'd be
cool if we could help them what's a
politician it was a person that should
good to help that person and shall
remain nameless I think I know who
you're talking about
yeah this is just a devil cat I guess
like an evil time maybe like hell is is
short for help or helpfulness and maybe
someone should add an L instead of the P
and someone said okay there's like a
really bad red ground there's a really
really bad evil person having to pull
whole load of heavy stuff
there's a Shaitaan first you get this
big blue arch when you walk in and it
says help is here and this was a big
sign that's in hell in the original
beginning but now it says help because
we've crossed it out and that's how I
think about animal therapy we ever a
little taxi that drove you here with a
very happy driver food where people
don't socialize and meet their healthy
food because health food makes you happy
this is on a lot of the red stuff in the
pink the grey stuff is like the ground
into volcanoes it's a really really bad
place and I suggest you apologize for
every bad thing you've done and never
ever do anything bad unless you want to
end up like this really really evil
person think of if you have a loved one
who who did something very bad or
murdered someone you're watching this
video this is how I want you to think
that they are if they've passed away I
think they're getting help I'm not gonna
lie I don't know if this is real or not
but if it is I really imagine this is
what hell is
[Music]
you